I'm fascinated by a couple of things
people that come from the same part of
the world that I do and are obsessed
with comedy and also people that have a
music
connection I've always been uh sort of a
frustrated music wannabe and I think
that there's a very strong connection
between music and comedy and uh and I
know that that was part of your
childhood because aren't your parents
professionals both
well yeah retired music teachers but my
mom was just you know the kindergarten
through eighth grade music teacher at a
small private school and my dad uh
taught the local College like music
history one and two
um but they're Eggheads for sure they
both have their phds in musicology as
does my sister in Coral conducting
and so I was like
you know they didn't have any money so I
was I was like this is no music's not
for me right and then I started being
like well maybe you could be a rock star
and that's a different deal right but
but then like I felt like you know I
could noodle on a lot of instruments and
then you'd meet the one kid who could
just shred a guitar and you're like well
yeah I don't I don't got it I don't got
it yes it uh it becomes cool it becomes
clear pretty quickly my theory and I've
mentioned it here A bunch of the podcast
is that when you're a kid you have a
checklist
and whether you're doing it consciously
or unconsciously you're kind of checking
out like
athlete but my creates it was athlete no
yeah yeah you know uh lady killer no
just like a lot of no's and then make
what's this thing is that a professional
I know what is what that's what you
wanted to get into no just
professionally no no no
[Applause]
what's your persona sort of a Ted Bundy
kind of thing you can still do it too
messy from state to state yeah yeah and
there's a uh no um that more more that
what are your assets I guess is that
what I would say that I guess that's
what I'm talking about what are your
assets and then you I finally just like
remembered no no no no no no no I seem
to be able to make people chuckle all
right we're just gonna double down on
that triple down on that everything's
going into that pot also you hit a
certain point where you're like this is
the only way I can figure out how to
feed myself
math is off the table Sports yeah
um modeling forget it what if I can just
squeeze a couple Chuckles out of
somebody
get by right yeah and you tried for a
while going on legitimate acting
auditions but it wasn't really until you
started making your own stuff
uh I knew that it just it was gonna hit
a wall so like both Rob and Glenn and
myself we were working uh the way
extraordinarily handsome young men in
the in their 20s can get some work sure
I did that yeah you know like like the
guy at the dock being like yeah I saw
him yeah you know yeah yeah
pretty decent guy hard working I think I
did notice Blood on the finger you know
like that like that how many Law and
Orders is that yeah yeah yeah that's
that is my favorite observation is uh
and it's the same thing for Dragnet and
Law and Order whenever they're
questioning someone it's like no no
anything else you want to say before we
go well there was one thing yeah he wore
a World War One German Helmet
you lead with that I don't know whatever
you make of that and then you know yeah
that's so you did a couple of like
online order and like a couple things
here and there and I was always coming
close I was testing for a lot of TV
shows to always to be the best friend
never to be the guy yeah yeah actually
one time uh
I got flown out for a show that was
called weird Henry and they're like well
maybe he could be weird Henry we he sure
seems weird and then uh you know I think
the studio saw the test and we're like
we're gonna cancel this show this is uh
the whole thing got scrapped after my
audition
um and then I booked a part on the Luis
Guzman sitcom
um
that was written by Will Gluck funny
talented guy and there were two writers
on that staff that I'm like these guys
are really really funny there's a Chris
Miller and Phil Lord oh yeah of course
so they went on to be pretty successful
um and uh that got canceled after three
episodes aired and it was around then
that Robin Glenn and I were thinking you
know
why wait why sit around and wait for
another one of these and then you don't
even necessarily like what you're being
given the opportunity to do why not just
shoot something ourselves and
I think we were looking at um
we were looking at the British office
yep and uh how sort of cheap it looked
it just seemed very handheld and very
easy to shoot and the lighting just
seemed like they threw the lights on in
an office and filmed it uh curb had just
come out around then and it felt the
same and uh
the Panasonic dvx 100a camera not that
we were big camera guys but somebody
Glenn or someone had stumbled upon this
camera and it kind of looked like those
shows but it was a for an affordable
camera
so that combination of of a attainable
look with an affordable camera and we
thought well we could shoot something
there was no
Tick Tock to just sort of throw it away
on right uh YouTube I think had was just
kind of coming onto the scene we thought
well let's let's shoot a pilot and we
made a a terrible pilot you know the but
there was a thing in it there was
something in the in the spirit of it
that we thought okay let's redo it
because it cost us nothing
and we had a lot of spare time and then
we said let's shoot it again
we shot a second episode and we sort of
handed that to our agents so we started
going around town and uh
or they said let's hook you up with a
big producer and we waited forever for
someone to watch it nobody watched it
um and while we were waiting we shot a
third episode and that third episode
started to get pretty good we started to
find our voice and our timing and get a
little bit better how to use the camera
and it was the third episode that uh Rob
had the his lack of patience was amazing
and very useful he was like I'm gonna
fire everyone unless we start getting
meetings and they're like okay okay
we'll set up some meetings and uh he
took it around and pitched it and um
we had an offer from
VH1 I think to rewrite it
and or maybe it was MTV
and we had an offer from FX to shoot a
pilot with a with a real budget and buy
a real budget I mean like one tenth of
what a television show was made for but
that was a hundred times more than what
we were working for uh
we shot that pilot they picked it up
they said we'll give you seven episodes
and then we did seven and then they were
like okay we're gonna we're gonna cancel
the show but uh unless you can get a big
name attached and
and Danny DeVito had seen the show and
liked it and then
here we are
still guys that's fascinating to me that
I mean you hear stories about you need a
big name yeah and uh and and I always
thought like it almost sounds apocryphal
like it's this thing from the 1940s or
50s but it's true yeah especially then
maybe less so now because there's so
many different things that you could
maybe launch something and and people
just the buzz of it being a popular show
on say Netflix people might check it out
but then
I think to to break through it all
yeah if we hadn't gotten Danny that
would have that would have been it now
how many seasons has it been now this is
going to blow my mind when you say it we
just shot the 16th that's unbelievable
to me and I think you've
broken the record or tied the record for
longest running yeah multicam sitcom is
something like that we passed Ozzie and
Harriet last year for the longest and
they did about a thousand episodes you
know oh my God we've done so many less
you know we've now we're only doing
eight a year
um but uh uh you know I think back then
they were like all right get to work and
you're gonna do 50 of these you know and
uh and but now you know so I yes we're
the longest running we haven't done the
most episodes and then cartoons like The
Simpsons has been around forever I'm
gonna tell me about it I left the
Simpsons in 1993. and I remember
thinking I remember thinking well this
thing's
this old horse has just about had it so
I'll just go do a late night show now
what are you at all thinking like
they'll never survive without me yeah no
I'm I'm deluded but not that deluded no
I knew that they survived very well uh
that they would survive very well
without me and and probably be enhanced
uh but I but
um yeah I left and remembered thinking
like well this thing has now been
chugging along for like six seven
seasons and it's a animated show and
it's very labor intensive how could it
possibly continue cut to 30 years later
that's insane 30 years time for them to
stop
yes I do
I only said that because I still am I'm
good friends with many of the people
that still make it so yeah they know I
don't feel that way but this is really
funny for me to go yes they should stop
immediately have they had enough
episodes for the characters to have aged
a year if theoretically well it's the
beauty of it and of course they have
right 300 five episodes oh yeah easily
they easily have but I mean that's the
conceit right they never get older
that's they never get older and Mr Burns
never remembers who Homer Simpson is
that's my other favorite Simpson hey
yeah and no one knows how old well sir
he saved your life he once was in charge
of the Moon uh he you know whatever they
you transplanted your lungs into his
once uh you once adopted him all these
ah it doesn't ring a bell which is a
great great conceit